- La démarche est peut-être
un peu moins fluide qu'avant,
mais l'amour du sport
est toujours aussi fort.
Émilien Vallée essaie de jouer
au tennis tous les jours.
Qu'aime-t-il de ce sport?
Sa réponse désarme
par sa simplicité.
ÉMILIEN VALLÉE, joueur de tennis
- C'est frapper une balle puis
essayer de la mettre en jeu.
Si elle va en jeu, bien là,
comme les professionnels font.
Ils aiment ça, eux autres, hein.
Bien moi aussi, j'aime ça,
mais je suis un amateur.
- Il a transmis sa passion
du sport à ses cinq enfants,
en particulier à Denis
et Gaétan, qui viennent échanger
des balles avec lui.
DENIS VALLÉE, fils d'Émilien
- Il en a reperdu un petit peu
à cause qu'il n'a pas fait
d'activité pendant un an et
demi, mais là, ça le revigore.
GAËTAN VALLÉE, fils d'Émilien
- Ça me rend heureux. Ça me rend
émotif aussi parce que c'est pas
donné à tout le monde de pouvoir
jouer avec son père rendu
à 91 ans. Mais ça me donne
surtout la chance de le battre
maintenant.
- Aller jusqu'à l'âge de 75 ans,
il n'y en a pas un
qui me battait.
- Il a d'ailleurs remporté
des tournois en Floride
pour les 70 ans et plus.
Monsieur Vallée a d'ailleurs
choisi sa résidence parce qu'il
y avait un terrain de tennis
dehors, mais les partenaires
se font rares.
Ça ne l'arrête pas.
- J'aime autant jouer tout seul
maintenant. Le jeu que je
me suis fait, là, j'adore ça.
Je joue 1 h 30, 2 h, puis
je frappe à peu près 100 balles.
- Il a toujours eu du succès
dans le sport. Au tennis,
mais aussi à la balle molle,
au ballon-balais et a même
à des tournois à Télé-quilles,
jusqu'à ce que l'ancien menuiser
se coupe deux doigts
au travail.
- Je travaillais à l'hôpital
Royal-Victoria. Et puis...
Une chance que j'étais
à l'hôpital quand je me suis mis
la main sur la scie.
Ces deux petits doigts-là,
ils servent plus beaucoup.
Fait que je me sers du majeur,
puis du pouce, puis un peu
de l'index. C'est comme ça que
je joue depuis plusieurs années
et puis ça va très bien.
- Il a aussi dû se faire opérer
à coeur ouvert en 2014.
Il est aujourd'hui en pleine
santé et nous dit avec un clin
d'oeil que son oncle Napoléon
a vécu jusqu'à 106 ans.
- Et voilà, et voilà ce que je
voulais vous montrer, mes amis!
- Émilien Vallée croit dur comme
fer qu'il ne sera jamais trop
vieux pour jouer au tennis.
Ici Antoine Deshaies,
Radio-Canada, B